♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
GREETINGS FROM CALIFORNIA, WHERE
COMING LIVE FROM THE NIXON
LIBRARY OUTSIDE LOS ANGELES.
SEE IF YOU REMEMBER HEARING THE
STORY AT ANY POINT BEFORE.
A CARAVAN OF IMPOVERISHED
MIGRANTS IS NOW MAKING ITS WAY
UP FROM CENTRAL AMERICA THROUGH
MEXICO.
THEIR PLAN IS TO PRESENT
THEMSELVES AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER AND DEMAND ENTRY INTO OUR
COUNTRY WITH ALL THE BENEFITS
THAT ENTAILS.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS VOWED TO
STOP THIS CARAVAN USING THE
ARMED FORCES IF NECESSARY, BUT
IT KEEPS COMING.
HAVE YOU HEARD SOMETHING LIKE
THAT BEFORE?
WELL, IN FACT, YOU HAVE.
SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR HAPPENED
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO.
WE WATCHED ANOTHER MIGRANT
CARAVAN MAKE ITS WAY UP FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA.
IT FINALLY ARRIVED, AND THE NEWS
COVERAGE ESSENTIALLY STOPPED.
BUT WHAT HAPPENED NEXT?
WILL HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED NEXT,
HUNDREDS OF THOSE PEOPLE IN THAT
CARAVAN ARE STILL HERE IN THE
U.S.
AND IF RECENT HISTORY IS ANY
GUIDE AT ALL, VERY FEW OF THEM
WILL EVER LEAVE.
ONCE YOU REACH THIS COUNTRY AND
CLAIM ASYLUM, YOU ARE USUALLY
HOME FREE.
OUR MEDIA DON'T OFTEN COVER
THAT, BUT THE REST OF THE WORLD
IS WATCHING AND NOTICES VERY
WELL.
THAT IS WHY THEY KEEP COMING.
THE MOST RECENT ESTIMATES
SUGGEST THAT A CARAVAN'S WORTH
OF UNINVITED MIGRANTS ARRIVES AT
OUR BORDER EVERY FEW DAYS.
WHY IS THIS HAPPENING?
BECAUSE AN ENTIRE POLITICAL
PARTY IS INVITING IT AND
ENCOURAGING IT.
THEY BELIEVE UNCHECKED
IMMIGRATION WILL STRENGTHEN
THEIR HOLD ON POWER.
THEY ARE PERFECTLY AWARE THAT
YOU DON'T LIKE THIS, BUT THEY
DON'T CARE.
JUST YESTERDAY, NANCY PELOSI
SAID IT WOULD BE "IMMORAL" TO
BUILD A WALL THAT WOULD STOP OR
PEOPLE FROM PUTTING INTO THIS
COUNTRY.
WATCH.
>> WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING OTHER
THAN BUILDING A WALL.
WHICH YOU CATEGORIZE VERY WELL.
IMMORAL, EXPENSIVE, INEFFECTIVE,
AND IT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
PEOPLE DO BETWEEN COUNTRIES.
>> Tucker: DID YOU CATCH THAT?
SECURING THE BORDER IS JUST "NOT
SOMETHING PEOPLE DO."
NOT SOMETHING DECENT PEOPLE DO,
ANYWAY.
BIGOTS DO IT, SO DO MORAL
REPROBATES AND ANYONE WHO
DERIVES PLEASURE FROM CRUELTY.
AS MSNBC EXPLAINS JUST TODAY,
BORDERS ARE A LOT LIKE SLAVERY
AND THE TRAIL OF TEARS.
WATCH.
>> THIS IS A MORAL OUTRAGE, THE
WORST EXCESSES IN THE HISTORY OF
THE COUNTRY, THE SEPARATION OF
FAMILIES AT THE AUCTION BLOCKS
TO THE SEPARATION OF NATIVE
AMERICAN FAMILIES.
IT IS A MORAL OUTRAGE.
>> I LOVE YOU, I REALLY DO.
I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE --
>> Tucker: THEY ARE MORALLY
OUTRAGED.
WELL, THEY ARE ALWAYS MORALLY
OUTRAGE PAIRED THE POINT OF
THEIR MORAL OUTRAGE IS VERY
CLEAR, AMERICA HAS NO RIGHT TO
DECIDE WHO LIVES WITHIN ITS
BORDERS.
AMERICANS LACK THE MORAL
STANDING TO MAKE THAT DECISION.
WE ARE TOO SINFUL.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS COME HERE
BECAUSE WE DESERVE IT.
WE MEDDLED IN THEIR WARS IN THE
1980s, WE HAVE THE GALL TO GET
ADDICTED TO THE DRUGS THEY SEND
US, WE ONCE HAD SEGREGATION IN
THE AMERICAN SOUTH.
WHATEVER, THE POINT IS THIS IS A
FALLEN COUNTRY.
22 MILLION ILLEGALS WITHIN OUR
BORDERS IS JUST THE BEGINNING OF
OUR PENANCE.
LATIN AMERICA IS LISTENING TO
ALL OF THIS, AND THEY ARE
GETTING THE MESSAGE, THAT IS WHY
THEY ARE ON THEIR WAY.
LAST FISCAL YEAR, 94,000
FAMILIES FROM HONDURAS,
GUATEMALA, AND EL SALVADOR WERE
DETAINED AT THE U.S. BORDER.
NOT ONE OF THESE PEOPLE HAD A
RIGHT TO COMMIT.
BUT THEY WERE NOT DEPORTED.
ALMOST 100% OF THEM ARE STILL
HERE, AND MOST WILL NEVER LEAVE.
WE ARE POWERLESS IN THE FACE OF
THIS.
CONGRESS COULD FIX IT, BUT
CONGRESS REFUSES TO FIX IT.
THE SYSTEM IS BROKEN BY DESIGN.
VOTERS KNOW THIS, OF COURSE, ONE
OF THE MAIN REASONS THEY VOTED
FOR DONALD TRUMP TWO YEARS AGO.
IF THEY DON'T HATE IMMIGRANTS,
OBVIOUSLY, BUT THEY DO BELIEVE
THAT AMERICA HAS A RIGHT TO
DECIDE WHICH IMMIGRANTS TO
ADMIT.
ALL THE COUNTRIES HAVE THAT
RIGHT, DON'T THEY?
THAT WOULD BE AN INTERESTING
DEBATE.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THEIR
LACKEYS IN THE MEDIA DO NOT WANT
TO HAVE THAT DEBATE BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THEY WOULD LOSE, SO THEY
TRY TO BELIEVE THE POPULATION
INTO SILENCE.
>> THE G.O.P. ARGUMENT ON
IMMIGRATION ISN'T ONE THAT IS
OPTIMISM-BASED, IT IS
FEAR-BASED.
THIS IS A SCARE TACTIC.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT, THIS
IMMIGRATION IS A SCARE TACTIC HE
IS USING TO WRAP UP HIS
SUPPORTERS.
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WHITE
ANXIETY.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT OLD, WHITE
MEN ANGST.
SO WHEN THEY BRING UP THE
CARAVAN, THAT IS ALL WE NEED TO
DO IS BRING UP THE PICTURES OF
CHILDREN BEING SEPARATED FROM
THEIR FAMILIES.
>> Tucker: IN OTHER WORDS,
SHUT UP RACIST.
YOU'VE PROBABLY HEARD THAT
BEFORE, TOO, EVERY DAY FOR THE
LAST FEW YEARS.
YOU HEAR IT A LOT BECAUSE IT IS
AN EFFECTIVE POLITICAL TACTIC,
BUT IT ONLY WORKS IF YOU FALL
FOR IT.
YOU SHOULD NOT FALL FOR IT.
MOST AMERICANS ARE NOT RACIST,
NOT EVEN CLOSE.
THEY ARE DECENT PEOPLE.
THEY LOVE THEIR COUNTRY, THEY